she has become one of the most prominent
figures of the Iranian protest movements
climber alness rakabi who took part in
an International Championship without
wearing a headscarf now a week after the
competition concerns remain over her
whereabouts and safety Iranian
authorities promised she wouldn't be
punished or suspended from competing
over the incident after rakabi
apologized and claimed it all had
happened unintentionally she received a
hero's welcome back in Tehran but now
media reports claim that following her
return she was forced to confess under
duress and placed under house arrest
the new york-based center for human
rights in Iran has appealed to
climbing's International body to protect
the athlete tweeting don't take the
government in Iran's word at face value
it has a documented history of detaining
maiming and killing those who oppose it
and rakabi isn't the first Iranian
female athlete to be caught up in a
hijab controversy Shore bayat is an
Arbiter for the international Chess
Federation in 2020 while competing at
the World Chess Championship in Shanghai
she also fell foul of Iranian
authorities because of her headwear Miss
Bayard welcome to the day I want to talk
about your particular case in a minute
but first I'd like to hear your reaction
to the case of elness rakabi is a reason
to worry about her safety
uh I think you'll notice about our
champion he made the bigger decision but
not wearing heavy scarf during the
tournament and this is showing uh I mean
in action she showed that she's a pretty
Iranian people and supporting the
revolution in Iran so of course I'm
avoid or her safety because we know
Iranian regime we know that it's a
brutal regime and it doesn't respect to
Human Rights and freedom of speech so I
also heard the news about Elena's I
heard that she doesn't have access to
her phone she's a we saw that a photo of
her was published on media visiting a
Ministry of sport and then it was like
she's apologizing and then another
person
her Instagram but her actions doesn't
match with these things so that's why
I'm going for hair safety you yourself
took a courageous stand against Iran's
oppressive rulers tell us what happened
uh yes as you know I'm an international
auditor I was auditing in the demons
World Chess Championship tournament in
2020 then also it is when the official
of Iranian Chess Federation told me my
hijab is not proper actually my hijab
was totally acceptable by Iranian
standards and they were demanding me
more so I decided to protest against it
and then I pushed my stuff even
back more to show more of my hair so
that they cannot you know bother me it
was like sending a message to them to
stop harassing me over hijab but the
next day I saw that all Iranian media I
mean the important news agencies belong
to the Iranian regime
I mean they condemned me for not paying
hijab and there was also interviews with
the president Dr Federation saying that
we have nothing to do with her and you
know she's not with us were you
surprised by the harsh reactions sorry
were you surprised by those reactions
coming out of Iran
of course I was very surprised because I
couldn't predict that this is going to
happen because still I had my head scarf
on my hair but I was on my head but I
was deciding to show more of my hair so
that they don't harass me to the pro
more proper hijab and demanding any more
and more so yeah this was checking for
me but then when I saw everything on
media it was like I couldn't believe it
it was just shocking because they ever
condemned me and then my social media
was uh people that are messaging me uh
sending me this screenshots from
different news agencies it seemed like I
was kind of Everywhere by the government
by the regime and then the Federation
asked me to write and write a public
apology letter and to post it in my
social media to post it on my Instagram
and at the main meantime they patched my
photo from their you know you know from
the telegram channel so that that was
really a message for me then um I I
asked them to send me a letter uh that I
will be excited if I come back to Iran
first they said that they will send me
this letter but they never sent it and
you know then there was another
interview with the president of the
Federation so that we cannot send such
letter to that she's asking you never
returned to Iran how do you feel now
watching all the brave women and girls
out on the streets taking off their
hijabs and standing up for their rights
I'm very proud of Iranian people
I always knew because I'm one of them I
always knew that we are
suffering from this mandatory hijab the
Iranian people are not against Egypt but
we are against mandatory Egypt we
believe in freedom of choice and so I'm
very proud of each and every person who
risking their life by coming to the
street to protest against a mandatory
scuff and not only that it's a movement
it's a revolution for women's rights and
human rights what would be your message
for the protesters back home we have
some 30 seconds left maybe if you had a
brief message for all the girls and
women out in the streets
I would like to tell them that I'm very
proud of them and I would like to tell
them that they are getting Brave and
braver each day and this is very
important that we stand together and we
support each other and our good times is
coming
sorry thank you so much for sharing your
story with us tonight
thank you